hi I'm Larry herb Xbox Live's Major
Nelson and welcome my friends to the
tactical taco party pack for plants vs.
zombies garden warfare now this taco
infused add-on will be available for
free on Xbox one and Xbox 360 on July
1st garden warfare has been a refreshing
take on the shooter genre infusing noir
lead our proceedings with Technicolor
visuals and humor at every single turn
so let's take a look at what the new
add-on has to offer first up is the
western themed jewel Junction map the
key set piece here is the train
barreling through the center of the map
at regular intervals but jewel Junction
is also home to a number of fun Easter
eggs
fans of Commander Shepard should keep a
sharp eye out the map will be playable
in team vanquish gnome bomb
garden ops and most importantly the
brand new game mode vanquish confirmed
for those of you unfamiliar with the
concept you're only given credit for a
kill in vanquish confirmed when you pick
up the Fallen enemies dog patch sorry
I mean crazy orange this creates a risk
versus reward mechanic as you decide
whether it's worth a danger of crossing
open grounds to secure the orb and a
point for your team
in addition to the math a new game-mode
the tactical taco party pack also has a
few noteworthy improvements for the game
for example there are eight new special
waves and one new challenge in garden
ops to bring some added variety to the
mix you'll find two brand new character
variants to play as well the citrus
cactus which pelts enemies with orange
wedges in a three round first as well as
the berry shooter whose extra-wide
splash damage is balanced out by a
slower rate of fire there's also a new
mixed mode eight versus a playlist that
includes gnome bomb vanquish confirmed
team vanquish and gardens and graveyards
finally the team also has overhauled the
party matchmaking system to make
inviting joining and starting matches
with friends easier we hope you enjoyed
this foray into tactical tako goodness
for plants vs. zombies garden warfare
thanks everyone for watching